- Hello everybody.
Can you hear me
with your headphones on?
All right, good?
All right, cool.
Let's just get a little
quick show of hands.
I always like to do this.
How many of you use SFTP...
How many of you use
an MFT, a managed file transfer,
or are responsible for delivering an MFT?
Great.
How about AS2, the protocol?
EDI?
Anyone here?
Okay, see some.
And how about partners here
who are helping our customers
with their journey?
Nice, I know.
I recognize a few here.
Awesome.
Look, y'all are in the right session here.
STG 339, helping customers modernize
their managed file transfer
with event driven SFTP.
I'm Smitha Sriram,
I lead the product management
for AWS Transfer Family.
Joined by me is Suh,
who's also the PM
for Transfer Family,
and Prabir,
principal solutions
architect for transfer.
So yeah, before the
afternoon slump gets...
Kicks in, let's get started.
So I'm gonna talk a little bit
about managed file transfer and EDI,
just level setting
on what that means to you
and our customers.
And then talk a bit about trends
that I've been hearing,
and how those trends are informing
our roadmap and our approach
to this space.
And then, I'm gonna hand
that over to Suh,
who's gonna do a deep dive
into features that underpin
our MFT and EDI offering.
Then Prabir has a demo showing
how you can build a cloud native MFT.
There's some agentic in there,
so I'm not gonna steal his thunder
with that demo talking about it now.
And we'll wrap it up,
we won't have time for Q&A here
but me and my colleagues
can meet you outside
if you want to talk more.
So as your businesses grow, right?
So does your data and data sources.
And in order to get value
from that data,
you want data to be mobile.
For best of class data mobility,
you need an MFT strategy
that can help you move data
securely, effortlessly, and efficiently
within your organization and across.
And this value means different
for many of...
For different customers.
For example, right?
If you're in the payments, reconciliation,
or you're healthcare company needing
to process claims and claim payments,
you perhaps need to interact
with a clearinghouse for settlements.
Or you are a producer
of value added data sets
that you want to sell,
you want a robust MFT
that helps you grow
your subscriber base.
Many of our customers use MFT
to automate their internal processes,
from HR, to finance, to payroll.
Customers in healthcare, pharmaceutical,
or financial services have to
regularly submit filings
to regulatory bodies,
like the FDA or SEC,
and that's where an MFT has helped
them streamline those submissions.
A big industry, or group of industries,
are supply chain and logistics,
where MFT is used
for exchanging transactional data,
like purchase orders,
shipping notifications.
And for all of these customers,
building their data pipeline using
their MFT data has become super important.
As such, there are four pillars
that we see that underpin an MFT.
One is support for industry
standard protocols.
So you have a business application
that resides in your environment
and your trading partners' environment,
and the common denominator for them
to communicate are SFTP, AS2,
I said EDI, X12.
So these data formats make it seamless
for applications and users
across environments to communicate.
Second is authentication
and access control.
So you give access to data
that your users should
only be able to see and use.
Processing and automation
so that you can build a data pipeline
from this data end to end.
And fourth, and most important,
is robust auditing to meet
your data security and regulatory needs.
Some of the trends that I'm hearing,
starting with security,
has always been a priority
and will always be.
Customers are looking for secure
and reliable SFTP and MFT in the cloud.
Second is tools that give them
proper governance so that they're able
to track, audit what's happening,
who's accessing the data,
who has access to what kind of data.
And third is simplicity,
so that they manage
as less infrastructure as possible,
and make it easy to build their MFT.
And lately, three more
trends have popped up.
One is, I mentioned, automation.
So they want their trading
partner relationship
to serve a double duty,
even as a data pipeline.
So as they're transacting,
they're also able to get
real time insights into that data.
By running analytics,
a lot of these customers are
also looking to become AI ready,
and innovate in their own business areas.
And that's exactly the reason
we launched AWS Transfer Family
here at re:Invent 2018.
Our team has seven years of experience
in helping customers like you modernize
your MFT.
The service is fully managed,
highly available,
and scales in real time
to meet your business needs.
There are a lot of features
that we've developed over the years
that help you migrate
from existing MFT systems
without having to change a lot
where it's difficult to change,
let's say your business
partner integrations.
So we make it easy so that
you can accelerate your migration.
AWS Transfer Family is built
on event-driven paradigms
so that you get run
the whole processes.
Gone are the days
of (indistinct) writing scripts.
Now you can plug into Amazon EventBridge
and automate your processes end-to-end.
And finally, and most importantly,
the service comes built-in
with industry standard compliance,
such as HIPAA eligibility, PCI,
to help you meet your
security requirements.
More recently,
we launched AWS B2B Data Interchange,
which is a managed EDI service.
The service helps you automate
the translation, validation,
and generation of X12 documents.
Again, the service is fully managed,
just like AWS Transfer Family,
and it's pay-as-you-go,
like any managed cloud service.
A favorite feature of mine is
the use of generative AI
to generate mapping code between X12
and your custom format
for JSON and XML, and vice versa.
So that has really helped
our customers accelerate
their EDI migration using this service.
So just a little bit
into the resources that we provide.
Suh is gonna go deeper into
some of the features we've added.
We offer...
We started...
We launched the service
with SFTP servers.
So you have SFTP, FTP clients
anywhere in the world who can connect,
and the files land in your S3 bucket
or EFS file system.
And then, we added a feature
called "SFTP connectors"
so that you may need to talk
to external SFTP servers.
Now, whether they are located
on a public IP,
or even accessible
over a private network,
you can use SFTP connectors
to talk to those servers.
Now, more recently,
we added Transfer Family web apps,
which is a managed web UI
for non-technical users
in your organization
to access files stored in S3.
Suh's gonna talk more in detail
about Transfer Family web apps
and how you can use it to empower
those business users.
And look, with the files
in your Amazon S3 bucket,
as many of you know,
the possibilities are endless
on what you can do with that data.
As an example is EDI processing,
I wanna take a moment
to thank tens of thousands
of customers around the world
who are using AWS Transfer Family today.
And one specific customer that
I'm excited to talk about is FICO.
So FICO, they help customers
in around 80 countries globally,
with anything from protecting
credit cards from fraud,
to increasing financial inclusion,
to improving supply chain resiliency.
Now, as a global leader
in credit card scoring and analytics,
FICO processes massive amounts
of sensitive data using
managed file transfer,
which means security
and efficient file transfer is
super important for
their business operations.
They were using a legacy MFT,
and with that the problem was
they had to manage
a lot of infrastructure,
even when they weren't using it,
which resulted in overhead and costs.
They embarked on a journey to modernize
their MFT using AWS Transfer Family,
and now they've eliminated
a lot of infrastructure,
reduced their deployment time,
because now they can use
infrastructure-as-code
and also lowered their TCO.
They also now can track their costs
more granularly and accurately
as they roll out Transfer Family
across FICO's multiple business units.
There's a QR code there
that goes into detail
on FICO's MFT transformation journey.
Another customer,
they don't need an introduction, right?
BMW Group, a global leader
and manufacturer of
vehicles and motorcycles.
They developed a vision,
sound, and analytics service on AWS.
Now, to keep up with
their reputation of delivering
high quality vehicles,
they used AI and analytics
to analyze the image and audio assets
from their production line.
But in order to do that,
they needed their camera data
to go into AWS.
AWS Transfer Family helped bridge
this camera data into Amazon S3
by SFTP the data directly
into their S3 buckets,
and with low latency.
Now, with that,
now all of this data into S3,
they're now able to process and deliver
very compelling analytics
with high quality.
And they store
about 1.3 million files
worth 1.3 petabytes
in Amazon S3.
Let me take also a moment
to talk about our partners.
We have a service delivery program
where we validate partners
who follow best practices
to deploy AWS Transfer Family
for customers' MFT implementation.
For example, ScaleCapacity recently helped
the city of Los Angeles save
substantial costs by migrating
their MFT to AWS Transfer Family,
and that QR code goes into detail
about ScaleCapacity and city of LA,
a public sector customer.
Another partner story
that I wanna share is Bizcloud Experts.
So they are a leading IT consultant
and DevOps company
who helps businesses empower
with scale and confidence
as customers innovate.
So a supply chain
and logistics customer
approached Bizcloud Experts
because they were struggling
with their EDI infrastructure
because of overhead.
Similar story with overhead and costs.
Now, this customer were managing
about 100 plus trading partners
and exchanging 250,000 messages per month.
Bizcloud Experts stepped in, right?
Developed expertise in AWS Transfer Family
and B2B data interchange,
and helped this customer migrate
their EDI to these services
within a very short amount of time.
So short, they did not have
to renew their license.
As a result,
the customer saved over
a million dollars annually.
And also, not only cost savings,
they also reduced
their trading partner onboarding time
because now they have full control
over the process.
So this is a great story.
Again, another QR code,
so you can read about more customers
who have benefited from our services.
All right, with that,
I'll hand it off to Suh
so she'll talk about the features.
- Great.
Thanks, Smitha.
And it's so great to be here
with you all.
So Smitha gave you all a great overview
as to the common use cases,
trends in MFT and EDI,
and an overview of our service.
Now, in this part,
I wanna talk a little bit more
about some of the specific features
that you can use to build
end-to-end complete MFT
and EDI workflows.
We're gonna start with talking
about the launches for this year.
The great news is everything
I talk about today will be tied
to a recent launch
that you can see highlighted in pink.
Unfortunately, I don't have time
to go into every single launch
but after this, as Smitha mentioned,
Prabir, Smitha and I
will be sticking around
to make sure we answer any
and all of your questions,
and we're looking forward
to the discussion.
We're gonna return to
this service overview
that Smitha had gone over earlier,
and we're gonna use this
to really navigate through
the various modular offerings
of Transfer Family and B2Bi.
And here, I wanted to start with servers.
Transfer Family servers are
fully managed endpoints
that eliminate the need for you
to have to manage or maintain
your file transfer infrastructure.
For servers today,
we support protocols SFTP,
FTP, FTPS, and AS2.
And because servers are fully managed,
they're scalable, they're secure,
and they scale to your demand,
we're finding that a lot of customers
like you are using servers
as the foundation for your MFT,
whether this is for use cases
like B2B exchange,
or you are integrating your applications,
or you are managing data distribution.
Now, when we're talking about servers,
and especially if you're in
a regulated industry,
like financial services or healthcare,
your first priority is
often networking controls.
And in 2018,
we launched a service
with a public endpoint.
And the public endpoint is
really simple to set up.
In the console, you could set this up
with a few clicks,
and then your external
partners can start connecting
and transferring files
over the public internet
to a managed host name,
and it lands in your S3 bucket.
And we also use this managed host name
for high availability, failover,
and load balancing as well.
And also, on the public endpoint,
there's built-in endpoint protection
that benefits you as well.
But as we are talking to you,
we started to learn from you
that you wanted more control,
and you wanted more control
over who can access your endpoint.
And you also sometimes didn't want
public internet at all.
And that's why we launched
the VPC endpoint,
where you can choose
to make this internal.
So anything that routes
into your VPC,
so this is great for
your internal pipelines,
your users can connect over VPN
or direct connect
and this is great if you're...
You can manage access
through your security groups
and things like that.
But what if you want the best
of both worlds?
You want to open up
your VPC endpoint to the public internet
while you still wanna leverage
the existing controls
in your security groups.
And you can also choose to make
your VPC endpoint internet-facing as well.
You can choose which elastic IPs
to bind to your internal IPs
and you can still leverage the controls
in your VPC and in your security groups.
And also, you can also specify
non-standard ports that
you may be interested in,
alternate ports that Transfer
Family support today,
like port 2222 or port 2223.
And also, for this,
I wanted to mention that
a few months ago,
we support IPv6
for both the VPC endpoint
and for public endpoints as well.
So now, the benefit of this is
with a dual stack endpoint,
you can support clients
that are IPv6 and IPv4-enabled,
without having to transition
to IPv6 all at once.
Now, that we've talked about
who can access your endpoint,
now let's talk about who
can authenticate to them.
Transfer Family today supports
three authentication modes.
The first is "service managed"
for simple key-based authentication.
And this is great for
getting started quickly.
You can manage create users, right?
In Transfer Family,
and you can manage your users
in the console as well.
We also support a direct integration
with AWS Directory Services.
So if you're using AWS-managed AD
or you're using AD Connector,
you can simply select
your domain in the console
and use this with
your existing users and groups.
This is great if you want
to maintain consistent access.
And then, our third,
most flexible option is
the custom identity provider,
or custom IdP option.
There's two deployment models
you can use here.
You can call Lambda directly,
which is great for
straightforward authentication flows,
and what we recommend generally.
But you can also route
through API gateway as well,
which provides you the benefit
of being able to leverage
web application firewall
in front of your authentication endpoint
if you're looking for
more things like freight limiting,
geoblocking, and so on.
A few years ago,
with custom IdP,
we did announce the option
for multi-method authentication.
So now, you can specify
a combination of methods
that your users will provide.
For example, you can specify key-only,
password-only, key or password,
or key and password.
And how this would work is in
the initial authentication request,
your user would provide the key
and then the server would
then prompt for a password.
The final thing I want
to say here is that as
of a couple months ago,
we made it even more flexible
for your identity provider.
So now on a Transfer Family server,
you can dynamically shift between
whatever IdP option you're using.
And this is because we've heard
from you for use cases like,
let's say you start with a POC,
you wanna get started quickly,
you start with service managed
for key-based authentication.
Your POC goes off smoothly,
you're ready to move
your workload to prod,
but you don't want to
recreate your server.
And that's what this
capability allows you to do.
You can simply shift
between your IdP modes,
and there's zero downtime
to your users.
And double click a little bit
into the custom identity provider option.
The custom IdP option,
as I mentioned earlier,
is our most flexible option.
So it's an adapter,
and it can pretty much talk
to any IdP out there,
which is great for lift and shift
without having to worry about importing
your users or passwords.
But we also heard from you
that writing your custom IdP can...
Or writing your custom
adapter can feel daunting,
and you want a blueprint
for your specific IdP.
And also, your IdP,
you can't store
access-specific information
that Transfer Family needs
for your users.
And that's exactly why
our SA community,
in partnership with our service team,
launched a Transfer Family
custom identity provider solution,
which is an open source
standardized option
that you can use.
And it's easy to deploy
with some templates
over infrastructure-as-code.
And it also has several
ready-to-use modules
for popular identity providers
you may already be using,
like Cognito, Okta, Entra.
You can see the list on the screen.
And finally, there are several
built-in best security...
Security best practices built-in,
like granular per user controls.
So you can specify things
like IP allow listing per user,
or per IdP.
And with this option,
this really gives you the flexibility
while maintaining security best practices.
A few months ago,
and Prabir's gonna talk
a little bit more about this,
I won't go too deep here,
but we already supported Terraform
for Transfer Family resources,
but we invested
in Transfer Family specific modules
and Terraform,
which gives you the benefit
of being able to automatically provision
and deploy Transfer Family resources
along with your existing infrastructure.
And as of a couple weeks ago,
we also announced Terraform support
for custom IdP.
So there's a QR code there,
and I'd love for you all
to check it out
and give us feedback.
All right, so we've talked about access,
we've talked about authentication.
Now, let's talk about storage.
Transfer Family directly integrates
with Amazon EFS and Amazon S3
so your users can transfer files
to two EFS file systems and S3 buckets.
For more granular controls,
we also support S3 access points,
which, through unique access endpoints,
you can specify permission policies
and network controls.
Now, earlier you may
have heard Matt Garman
in his keynote sharing
that S3 access points
now supports FSXN.
Well, I'm super excited
to share that Transfer Family
also supports this integration,
and also supports S3
access points with FSXN.
And I'm really excited about
some of the hybrid access patterns
that this will open up.
For example,
your external users can
continue transferring files
through SFTP,
while your internal
users can continue using
familiar protocols, like NFS and SMB.
And getting started is simple.
Just create an S3 access point
for your FSX file system,
and Transfer Family will talk to it
just like any other access point today.
And with this launch,
your users will be able
to perform file operations,
like upload, download,
delete, and copy.
While some limitations
to keep in mind are that rename
and append operations are not supported.
And there's also an upload file size
of five GB.
If you wanna learn more
about the full list
of what's supported and what's not,
there is a QR code where you can read
the launch bot to learn more.
Great, so we've talked about servers.
Now, let's talk about connectors.
So while servers are endpoints
that your clients connect to,
connectors work in reverse.
Connectors are fully managed SFTP clients
that connect to remote SFTP servers.
And how connectors work today is,
again, they establish a connection
to your remote SFTP source in S3.
And if you wanted to
initiate your connector,
you would do that through
a CLI or API calls.
Now, let's say you wanted to send
a file to your partner.
You can simply use a star file transfer
with the file path.
Now, let's say you wanted
to retrieve a file from your partner.
You just specify the retrieve file path
and the S3 destination.
Now, let's say you wanna check
what files are available.
To do that,
you can use StartDirectoryListing
to get a complete inventory
on the remote SFTP source.
Finally, let's say you finish processing,
you wanna clean up,
you can use remote file operations
that we recently supported,
which is move, delete,
and also rename as well.
If you wanna learn more
about these new operations,
there's a QR code
that I'd love for you to click into.
And just like we support VPC for servers,
I'm really excited to share
that we're bringing that same capability
to our SFTP connectors.
This means your SFTP connectors can
now connect to private SFTP servers
wherever they're hosted,
whether this is in
shared VPCs, on premises,
or in your partner environments
that are accessible through
your private networks.
All traffic does route
through your VPC environment.
So this allows you to
enhance your security
and comply with your security mandates
by traversing through
centralized firewalls
and traffic inspection points.
You present the...
You present the IP address,
which eliminates the need
for your partner to have
to allow us any additional IPs.
And finally, for heavy file volumes,
you get the full performance
of your NAT gateway.
Let's talk a little bit
about how to set this up.
So as a quick note,
this does not require you
to modify anything
in your existing VPC configuration.
However, this does require you
to set up two simple components
in VPC Lattice,
which is a feature of VPC.
So first, you would create
a resource gateway,
and you can think of this as a bridge
between Transfer Family
and your VPC environment.
Then create a resource configuration.
So this represents your
SFTP server address.
You can use either
the private IP address
or the public DNS name.
Then your resource gateway connects
your connector to these configurations,
and now can connect to
your remote servers through your VPC.
The best part again is that
there's no changes required
to your VPC environment,
and you can use your
existing security controls,
you can present your existing IP address.
Everything should just work.
All right, so now,
I wanna shift gears slightly
because what if the end user persona
we're talking about is different?
What if these are human users,
these are non-technical users
in your organization,
like your HR business partners
or your financial analysts, or so on?
All these people need
to transfer files to S3,
and for you S3 is where you wanna be
because it offers security,
durability, scalability, and so on.
But for your end users,
you want to, or you need to,
provide an easy-to-use experience
so that they can
easily upload and download.
And that's where Transfer
Family WebOps comes in.
Authentication is driven
through IAM Identity Center,
so your users can SSO
or present their existing credentials
that they're already using
for other applications.
Now, user permissions is driven
through S3 access grants.
So with Access grants,
you can really enable
fine grain access controls,
so your users only authorize the data
that they're authorized to access,
and they only have permissions
to the data that you allow them to have.
So for example,
read-only access or read-write access.
And finally with the web app,
and I'll go a little bit more
into the different options,
but you also have
a few customization options,
so your web app aligns
with your company brand.
Now, as to how to set up a web app,
it's pretty simple,
and you can set this up in the console
in just a few clicks.
And while you're setting up your web app,
you have a few options
where you can add a company logo,
you can add a favicon
or a browser tab icon.
You can also specify the page title,
which is what shows up
in the browser top
that's presented to your end users.
As WebOps is part of Transfer Family,
it shares compliance status,
like HIPAA eligibility,
FedRAMP, PCI, and more.
And most importantly, again,
with your end user in mind,
it's a simple to use experience
that's accessible through any browser
that they're already using.
And it's a drag-and-draw,
point-and-click experience.
Now, we launched WebOps
this time last year,
and in that year,
we've really learned a ton from you
as to what use cases
you're using WebOps for.
For example, we're hearing that
your finance teams are exchanging reports
through WebOps,
or your marketing teams
are uploading media assets
through WebOps,
or your research scientists
are collaborating
on datasets through WebOps.
There's a lot of use cases
and while they all sound different,
the underlying themes are the same.
One, easy to use end-user experience.
And the second is that
you're centralizing access
across your workforce,
again, using existing security controls
and identity credentials.
Now, if we look at this flow here,
it's straightforward.
So you as the admin
would create the web app,
you'd share the URL
with your end user.
Your end user would then access
the web app through the URL.
And then, they would SSO, or present,
or log in with their username,
password, MFA that they're already using
with whatever IdP that you're using.
And after the token exchange
between your IdP and Identity Center,
your user then lands in the web app
where they're only seeing
the files and folders that
you've given them access to access
either because of their user identity
or their group membership.
And then, they're only allowed
to perform certain actions that,
again, through S3 access grants,
you've given them permission to do.
The backend, all file transfers
are going direct to S3.
And in CloudTrail,
you can audit all user interactions,
down to the user identity,
so you're able to see who does what.
And just like we brought VPC support
for servers and for connectors,
I'm excited to share that
as of a few weeks ago,
you can also enable
a VPC endpoint for WebOps.
So with a VPC endpoint,
we create a service managed endpoint
within your VPC
at no additional charge.
Your users can now securely access
the web app through a web browser
while keeping all traffic
within your VPC.
So this is really important
if you have like internal teams
who need to handle sensitive documents,
and you have regulatory
or security mandates
that you're trying to meet.
And now, your users can connect
directly through Direct Connect,
or VPN, or from within your VPC.
You can also further enhance your security
by only allowing access
from approved client IPs.
And again, if you have
some mandates you need to meet,
you can do that through
through this feature.
Now, with this launch,
you have two flexible options
for using WebOps.
Through public endpoints,
your users can continue connecting
over the public internet,
which is great for
if you're using this with
external collaborators or partners.
And now, through a private endpoint,
your users can connect through
your VPC, direct connect, or a VPN.
And this is great, again,
for sensitive workloads
that might require
strict network controls.
You can choose
whatever deployment option works for you,
or you can use both depending on
who the user is within your organization.
Great, so we've talked about
different modes of being able
to transfer data through servers,
connectors, and now web apps.
But now I wanna shift gears slightly
because what happens if you need pre
or post transfer processing,
especially for your EDI workloads?
That's where B2Bi comes in.
We are seeing a lot
of customers using Transfer Family
and B2Bi together
for their EDI workloads.
And here's a typical architecture
that we see.
And I'm gonna start from the left
and just walk through.
So in this architecture,
your trading partner
is transferring files,
your EDI files,
through industry standard protocols
with Transfer Family,
like SFTP or AS2.
Transfer Family takes this file
and puts it in an S3 bucket.
B2Bi is listening to the event,
monitoring the bucket.
And now, as soon as the file arrives,
B2Bi is validating the EDI file,
it's translating it to JSON or XML,
and it's writing to transform data
into an output S3 bucket.
It also emits an EventBridge event
with the output location as well,
and the status.
Then this event triggers
any post-processing actions
you might want,
and allows your data to flow
into your business applications,
like your ERPs or your data lakes.
If you're interested in learning
more about architectures like these,
there's a QR code
where you can learn more.
We launched B2Bi
just a couple years ago
and as you can see,
we've been really busy investing
into the different features for B2Bi.
More so this year,
as you can see.
Most recently, we expanded support
into our first European
region, into Dublin,
to now support four regions.
And if you wanna learn more,
there is also another QR code
that you can click into.
Great.
With that, I've talked about
some of the components
that you can use to build
your modern MFT systems,
and now I'm excited
to pass off to Prabir,
who's gonna show you this in action.
- Thank you so much, Suh.
Now, building on top of some
of the components that Suh
and Smitha mentioned,
today, I'm gonna walk you through
how you can build
a modern managed file
transfer system using AWS
that leverages agentic AI.
Let me quickly highlight
the core building blocks.
We're gonna build our secure file transfer
by using Amazon AWS Transfer Family.
We're gonna add malware protection
by using Amazon GuardDuty.
And this is what makes
the solution truly modern.
So instead of using rigid code,
rules-based engines,
we're gonna use AI agents
to be the intelligence behind
our file processing.
Tying it all together is going
to be Amazon EventBridge,
which forms the foundation
of our event-driven architecture,
and this is what automates
the entire system.
How many folks over here use Terraform?
Awesome, quite a few of you.
So you'll be super excited to know
that the demo that
I'm gonna show you today is built
entirely using Terraform.
I will be linking the QR code in the end,
so please feel free to check it out.
There's some other examples
that you can also build on.
Now, for today's use case,
we're gonna take
a traditional insurance
claims processing system,
and we're gonna see how
we can modernize this using
our modern architecture.
Also, like how many of you are
from insurance or financial
services organizations?
Okay, I see a few of you.
So the use case that I'm
gonna show you today is
actually quite applicable to almost
all industries who do some kind
of file processing.
Typically, we start with an ingest phase
in which you may have
some kind of documents,
like for our use case,
we have policy documents,
images, or repair estimates
that are ingested in an SFTP folder.
The next up is our extract phase,
in which case most organizations do have
some kind of a basic OCR.
An OCR is a technique,
for those who know noise,
a technique to extract text from images.
The challenge with
traditional OCR is that
it is rigid,
it only expects files and formats
in a certain way.
And finally, our next phase,
or the last phase,
of our flow is the analysis phase,
in which typically there is
a bit of manual processing.
You may have some kind
of rules-based engine that does part
of the automation for you,
but this is where humans have
to kind of get involved
and you have the human in the loop.
The challenge with this entire approach is
that not only this is error prone,
it is time consuming,
and it just doesn't scale.
Now, let me walk you through
how you can modernize this
by using cloud-native architecture.
Now, here's our modern approach
that builds on top of
the core building blocks
that I spoke about,
secure file transfer,
malware scanning, and agentic AI.
I'm gonna show you a demo
that will be...
That will automate an end-to-end workflow
of claims processing using agentic AI,
all powered by event-driven architecture.
Let's dive deep into each
of those components to explore more.
Our first stage is where
we are modernizing our foundation.
We will replace our legacy SFTP servers
with Transfer Family,
which means that there's
no infrastructure to manage,
it automatically scales,
and is highly available.
Now we want to authenticate
external users,
and we do that by adding support
with custom IdP.
These external users could be anywhere
from repair shops to partners
that your company works with,
and it allows you to offload
and almost integrate with
their identity provider,
and you don't have
to do separate credential management.
Now, we want to store everything
in Amazon S3 for its unlimited scalability
and high durability for all your files.
In the next stage,
we will be adding
automatic malware scanning.
This is a requirement
for most regulated industries
to do malware scanning
of all files as they land.
So we're gonna achieve that
by leveraging GuardDuty's
native malware scanning capability.
GuardDuty offers
immediate threat detection
and intelligent file routing
for all your files.
What it means that
your clean files will land
automatically in a clean bucket,
and any malicious file,
or suspicious files,
move directly to a quarantine bucket.
All done through
event-driven architectures.
And lastly, when we talk
about intelligence layer,
this is where we've seen
a huge transformation happening
in industries that are trying to modernize
their traditional file
processing workflows.
So we are gonna be using
Amazon Bedrock AgentCore,
and we have AgentCore orchestrating
all of our AI agents.
Now, the agents themselves,
they can use the most sophisticated models
that are available not only in Bedrock,
even from other cloud providers.
So these could be from Anthropic,
the cloud models,
these could also be
our Amazon novel models.
And these in general offer
a lot more flexibility
and accuracy over a traditional CR.
Now finally, you wanna make
this accessible to human users
in a simple way.
So this is where
we use Transfer Family's web UI
or web apps feature
that is a simple browser-based access
for your end users
to access these files.
It's completely self-serve.
It has security built-in,
which means that it
provides rule-based access,
the right access to the right people
at the right time,
built on the principles of zero trust.
Now, let me show you
all of this in action.
It's probably the demo
that you've been waiting for.
And before I dive deep in,
I wanna mention that I've broken
this demo down into multiple stages.
You will see that in the code as well.
For this demo,
I've pre-deployed certain stages.
I have the Identity
Foundation pre-deployed,
I've set up a Transfer Family server
with custom IdP.
I've also set up our
automatic malware
scanning using GuardDuty.
Now, we are starting
with the dual identity system.
We are using IAM Identity Center
for our insurance users.
For this demo, I've traded local users,
but your IDC setup may
look very differently.
You may have already federated
with another identity provider.
You see, I have two users,
claim reviewers and claim admins,
and these are what I'm gonna be using
for our demo.
Now, for our external users,
I'm using Amazon Cognito
to simulate user management.
I've made Any Company insurance user
and you see Any Company repairs user is
the entity and identity
that I'm gonna be using throughout
the presentation of the demo.
I've also set up a transfer server,
so let's just check that out
in a second.
And if you look at
the identity provider configuration,
I set this up using custom AWS Lambda,
which is our custom IdP solution.
I've created a bunch of different buckets.
I am using my random page generators.
So if you like these names,
I'm glad you did.
All right, so we're gonna be using
our claims file to ingest
all our files.
But the bottom three buckets,
clean bucket, errors bucket,
and the quarantine bucket is gonna be used
by our malware scanning.
Now, to test our
event-driven architecture,
what I'm gonna do is that
I'm gonna upload a file.
And I'm using Kiro CLI by the way,
so I'm not typing SFTP commands.
I'm very clumsy so I thought
this was a better use of natural language,
by asking Kiro to do the work for me.
So what I've done is
that Kiro created a test file.
I've uploaded this to my bucket.
Kiro is also parsing logs from CloudWatch,
so it states that the GuardDuty scan has
now been kicked in.
And let's see what's happening.
So the first thing I see is
that my claims file...
Test file did land up in my SFTP bucket.
If my malware protection is working
as designed,
I should have seen this file
automatically processed.
And if I do a refresh,
it should end up in my clean bucket,
which is exactly what you see.
Now, I want to test the same thing
for my malicious file.
So I don't wanna infect my system,
so I'm using an ICAR file,
which is a test file that's used
to detect malware scanning.
It's the same flow...
I'm gonna be uploading this
into an SFTP folder.
Okay, so again,
Kiro's uploaded this file using SFTP.
We can double check in our console.
We see that this file did land up
in our SFTP folder.
Now, I also wanna double check
if my clean bucket is intact.
And if I quickly do a refresh,
I see that nothing's changed.
I still have my clean file
that I uploaded earlier.
But if I go into my quarantine bucket,
this is where the magic is.
GuardDuty automatically detected this
as a malicious file
and it moved this to
my quarantine bucket.
So now that I've done this again,
Kiro is summarizing all the findings
to detect everything that we saw
in the console,
so nothing new there.
Now, what I'm gonna do is that
I'm gonna actually deploy my stage three,
which is the agentic AI foundation layer.
And this is...
You can, by the way,
do this using a simple Terraform apply.
That's all that the Kiro is doing
on my behalf.
So the commands that you see over here,
they're not something from the Matrix,
they are a Terraform apply,
so most of you are familiar with this.
That's all I'm doing right now.
I wanna just quickly walk you through
a snippet of what my agents look like.
And what you see over here is
that instead of using complex logic,
I'm using a very simple prompt.
And if those who have used some kind
of chat-based interface,
such as ChatGPT,
this actually might look very familiar.
So I've actually asked this agent
to do something for me.
I've said that
"You are a claims
processing workflow agent.
"You use STRANDS.
"And your job is to extract entities,
"validate the damage claim,
"insert the enriched data
"into a database,
"engineer the summary."
So that is my instruction to this agent.
Now, the agent's gonna figure out
what to do and how to do,
and which subagent to engage.
Now, for this demo,
I'm actually using two
different claim files,
so I'm gonna just show you this
just in a second.
But before I do that,
let's check our agents in AgentCore.
Anybody using Agent Core today?
Okay, some of you.
All right.
So for those who are using this,
this might look very familiar.
I've deployed five different agents
and I'm using AgentCore Runtime.
That's exactly what we saw,
like we had five different agent files.
For this demo,
I've also created a DynamoDB table,
which, again, kind of simulates how
most financial services organizations do
downstream processing.
You may have some kind of database
that you will keep as a book of records
or downstream processing of claims.
Now, I'm gonna show you quickly
our claims files
that we're gonna be testing.
So our first claim is
a regular claim that ha...
Of a car that had a rear bumper damage
in a shopping car...
Shopping center parking lot.
There's an estimated repair cost of $995.
So just...
Yeah, some entities over here.
And I have an image of a car
that has a bump...
A fender bender,
so very consistent with what you saw
in the claims form.
Now, let's test this.
I'm gonna upload this
in the same process.
Our event-driven architecture,
we're gonna upload this
into our SFTP folder.
We see that's just happened.
NQO is gonna start parsing the logs.
Okay, it's the second phase
of our agentic AI was malware scanning.
We see that the file was
successfully uploaded
into my clean bucket,
and the agents actually moved them
to a submitted claims prefix.
So again, just for organization.
I see those same files that you saw.
Now, Kiro, I've actually asked you
to parse CloudWatch logs.
So instead of going to
CloudWatch console...
I like working the ID,
so that's what I'm doing, right?
So instead of going to the console,
Kiro is parsing the logs for me
and we see that our agents
successfully parsed the entities,
and now it's giving me a summary
of exactly what it found.
My agent says that
this damage is consistent,
it is 90% confident that
this claim is legitimate,
and it gave me a reason
why it thinks it's legitimate.
I've also instructed this agent
to write this file to an S3 bucket.
So that's exactly what it is.
So it's processed the claim
and it created a summary for me,
for my end users.
If I open this file,
this is the exact same thing
that we saw in the ID, right?
So basically, it says that there's a car
that had a minor bumper damage.
It is consistent with
the claim description.
So perfect, everything's fine.
Great, so it can be processed and paid.
I'm gonna do the same test
for our "claims 2" now.
We see our "claims 2" was
successfully uploaded.
So same flow, nothing's changed.
I see that my agents have
finished the processing,
it extracted the entities,
and now let's look at the results.
All right, so this claim is fraudulent.
That's what my agent says.
And it's 95% confident that
it is fraudulent.
Again, I didn't have to hardcore
any of this thing,
the agents did the reasoning.
Let's look at "Claim 2"
and understand why it is fraudulent.
So I'm just gonna quickly open "Claim 2."
If I look at my claim form,
it's a form that states that this car had
a minor front bumper scratch
in a grocery store parking lot.
There's some more description
about the scratch itself.
The scratch is about three inches long,
and so on and so forth.
Now, if I look at the image of this claim,
do you guys think this is a scratch?
Probably not.
By the way, no cars were harmed
in creating this demo.
This is all AI-generated.
This would've been
a very expensive demo otherwise.
Awesome, so remember,
I recreated DynamoDB table.
So one of my agents
also ingested meaningful entities.
Again, it knew exactly what to ingest
into a DynamoDB table.
So very consistent what we saw,
we have two claims.
One has a consistent damage,
which is labeled as true,
and the others as false.
All the entities that were extracted
by a claim form
and other metadata.
Now, all of this is great,
but we want to make this data accessible
to human users in a simple way.
Your human users are business users.
They're not gonna log into Kiro
and check out this data,
and they're probably not gonna log
into the (indistinct) console.
So this is where we are gonna be deploying
the web app's functionality.
So I just did the same thing.
I created web apps using Terraform,
and we see that the web
app has been created.
I'm gonna log into the web app using
its access point,
and I'm gonna use the two identities
that I created in the beginning
of the presentation,
which were my claim reviewers
and my claim admins.
For my claim reviewers,
I've given them read-only access.
And let's see if they have indeed
what I define in infrastructure-as-code.
As we see that our claims reviewer
only have access to read these files,
so our processed claims
and submitted claims,
again very consistent with what we saw,
we see that our two claims
from our S3 bucket.
And just to double check,
I can download this claim
and this is exactly what we saw.
But instead of going with the console,
typing SFTP commands,
this offers a very simple interface
for our end users.
I also wanna test the same thing
for our claims admins.
And for the claim admins,
I've given them rewrite access
to the entire bucket.
So they should ideally see,
if everything's working as designed,
a little more than what we saw
for our claim reviewers.
Perfect.
So they see the entire bucket,
they have rewrite access.
This is working as designed.
We see all the prefixes
that were in the bucket.
And just to test that
they have rewrite access,
I'm actually gonna delete
this claim file.
Perfect, so if I do a refresh,
I see that there are no files.
So again, this is working as designed.
Now, many of you may have
some questions about agents,
so I just wanna maybe double click on
how I've created these agents.
So AgentCore is the foundation over here
that's orchestrating all of our agents,
and I've built all of
these agents using STRANDS.
Anybody familiar with the STRANDS?
Okay, some of you are.
So STRANDS, for those
who are not familiar,
it's an open source SDK
that we built,
built by AWS,
that really allows you to create agents
in a very easy and flexible way.
Fun fact is that although
these agents that I built,
they were created in five minutes
or less using Kiro CLI,
so lots of prompting.
Yeah, and I would just wanna walk you
through what these agents are doing
at a high level.
So we have our entity detection agent,
and I've actually asked it
to detect entities
and extract entities
from my PDS.
I have my validation agent,
that has a multimodal
that is able to extract entities
and read the text,
and also compare it with my image.
So this is what's doing
the fraud detection, right?
And this is what kind of gave
the score that it's 90% confident,
or it's the validation agent's product.
Our summarization agent is creating
a meaningful summary that we all saw
in our S3 bucket
and also through web apps.
And our database agent ingested
all these records
into a DynamoDB table.
Now, the brain behind all of this is
our supervisor agent.
Remember the prompt that we saw earlier?
You guys remember?
So the prompt was for my supervisor agent
to decide which agent...
Which subagent to invoke at what time.
So the patent...
The reason why I'm showing this is
because this pattern is not
only applicable to insurance,
but it can be applied to
any industries, any use case.
So whether you're in payments,
whether you're in hospitality,
whether you're in healthcare,
this kind of shows you how you can take
a file processing workflow,
use agentic AI to transform
your file processing workflows,
add intelligence to it
by using agentic AI.
Now, before I wrap up,
I wanna emphasize that
what you saw isn't just a demo.
Everything that we built is powered
by our Terraform Transfer Family module.
I have given the QR code over here,
so if you wanna grab it,
please feel free to do so.
Today, we saw that we deployed
a Transfer Family server,
we deployed custom IdP support with it.
I set up malware protection,
agentic AI, web apps.
And this is just one
of many examples that we have
in our Terraform Transfer Family module.
They're all built around
real world use cases
that you can deploy
and use right away.
We launched this module
only a couple of months ago,
and we've already had
over 10,000 downloads.
And I just wanna call out
and thank the amazing solution architects
that have been contributing
to this module,
but also external contributors
such as you.
We've actually had a lot
of external contributions.
So if you are there in the room,
awesome, thank you.
We do maintain a public roadmap,
so if you like what we're working on,
please do a plus one on that
so we know where to focus on.
But if you think there is
anything that's missing,
please do create a GitHub issue.
My team and I,
we review these feature requests daily
and I'm like actually super excited
to see which
you will build using these modules.
So with that,
I'm gonna pass it on to Suh.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)
- Awesome.
Great demo, Prabir,
and so excited that this is
all supporting Terraform,
so I can do it later.
So for this,
we're just gonna wrap it up
with a few resources
and next steps for you all.
So hopefully, from this session,
you are able to take away
how simple it is to create a secure
and modern MFT system
using Transfer Family B2Bi.
And like Prabir's demo showed,
you're able to see how
you can unlock innovations using agents
with Transfer Family as well.
As for availability,
here are all the regions
that Transfer Family
is available in today.
All recent regions are
highlighted in pink.
At re:Invent, if you want to learn
more about Transfer Family,
and even rebuild what Prabir
just showed you,
here are some sessions for you
to check out as well.
And finally, here are some resources
with QR codes for you all
to save for later.
So we have our user guide,
where you can see end-to-end
tutorials, guidance.
Here's our website
where you can learn more
about our different offerings.
And most exciting to me is
a self-paced workshop that's hands-on,
so you can get your hands dirty
and build event-driven MFT workflows
for yourself.
With that, thank you so much,
and please reach out to
your account teams to connect to us.
We're looking forward to talking
more with you.
Thanks.
(audience applauding)